This smile is part living skin tissue and part robot.
It's the product of a decade of research by scientists at the University of Tokyo.
It may look a little eerie, but researchers say it could one day be used for testing cosmetics and medicine
and is an important step in the quest to make more life-like robots.
To create the smiling robot, scientists grew human cells into the shape of a face.
The smile is produced from embedded ligament-like attachments that pull it into a wide grin.
Here's lead researcher Shoji Takesuchi.
Until now, no one had figured out how to make the living skin move.
So I think by attaching these actuators and anchors, it became possible to manipulate living skin for the first time.
This is a new technology that we developed.
Takesuchi says living tissue has a number of advantages over metal and plastic, such as skin's ability to repair itself.
The hope is to add more features to the lab-grown skin, including a circulatory system and nerves.
Takesuchi says the work could potentially lead to safer testing for cosmetics and drugs, or be used to cover robots one day.
One problem he still faces is the so-called uncanny valley.
That's the unsettling feeling that comes when robots start to resemble humans a little too closely.
Takesuchi says he hopes to overcome it.
Various things have been talked about to reduce the creepiness, but I think one of the important matters is the materials.
I think that making robots out of the exact same materials as humans, and having them show the same expressions,
might be one key to overcoming the uncanny valley.